- Is it true that you get
mistaken for Nick Jonas,
'cause y'all both are in "Jumanji?"
- I, yeah, on a handful of occasions.
- This is amazing, and
I hope you go with it.
- [Colin] Well, and this.
- And sign his name.
- This needs to properly be
explained because someone
came up to me and say,
what's up, fake Nick Jonas?
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Fake Nick Jonas.
- And the reason why they said that was
because in "Jumanji," I
play like, the main kid
that gets sucked into
the game and in the game,
I was played by Nick Jonas.
- But in real life, when you come back
and you live your life.
- It's me.
- Yeah.
- So in reality, yeah,
he's fake Colin Hanks,
but no one calls him that.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] That's rude.
You know, and I will call him.
- No one calls him that and, you know.
- I'm gonna change his,
I'm gonna change his name
in my phone as fake Colin Hanks.
(audience laughing)
- Please.
- [Kelly] That's what I'm gonna do.
- I'll take the photo so it can be saved.
- I'm literally gonna do it
and I'm gonna, he's gonna love it.
He'll think it's funny.